the time for our top photos Anastasia
have a look at these we pick out three
everyday number three today is actually
a little bit of video because today
marks the 26th anniversary of the
Tiananmen Square protests can you
believe that in 1989 hundreds died after
China's Communist Party sent tanks to
disrupt Democratic protesters a
candlelight vigil will be held in Hong
Kong today to commemorate the
anniversary more than 150,000 estimated
to come it's the only place in china
mainland or Hong Kong where a
commemoration like this footage and
these photos almost didn't make it out
of China a couple years ago as part of a
project to talk the photographers there
were several do they have they had to
they had to hide rolls of film in their
in their rooms they had to switch them
they had to do the Chinese authorities
went hotel room to hotel room looking
for footage exactly this whatever you do
this summer go to the Met to relive this
moment in the basement of the met as we
speak is it completely at stamp 1968 Red
Guard uniform part of their magisterial
China exhibit right now it's it's off in
a corner it's like an afterthought of
all this fancy stuff and it's deeply
emotional to this film to see the red
vertices and the film is amazing because
what you don't see with that single shot
is it as the tank tries to move the man
standing in front of the tank moves back
and forth with it yeah does not let the
tank goes amazing amazing protest number
two sillon Asia but in Japan this time
Godzilla has been named the country's
new tourism and that word they ask
Taylor said she wasn't available the
Beast well Godzilla also received
residency papers his official duties
include drawing visitors from around the
world and watching over the kabukicho
neighborhood in Tokyo our producer is
telling us the precinct III h Prefecture
has its own mascot Godzilla's o is a
pretty it's a pretty good one alright no
one has any comment on that except me
number one in Taiwan a new trend is
emerging owners are trimming their dog's
fur into GM L shapes the initial idea
was to give pets and you clean cut look
and to make them stand out a little
inverness come here to sell on workers
say dogs are not hurt in the process
well I chose a no hotel Anastasia
emarosa weigh in on this come on in
Manhattan your fancy fancy man little
bark bark dogs going down the street
park bar you want to go like yeah yeah
pet dogs do you want to go with the
geometric or do you want to go with the
real beast well actually have one of
those dogs who just about got the
haircut Jasmine really sorry so with
that though is that dog the mascot of
this prefecture do you have been looking
at phone at the photograph cuz you're
not getting out of here okay i will show
you doing the right yeah terribly heavy
will come back Anastasia emarosa will
discuss geometric poodles when we
returned no I'm kidding